وطبعا نذكر بان حجم الدمار لحق خصوصا في
الولايات المتلاصقه في جنوب تركيا
بالتحديد ولكن اذا ما اردنا نتحدث عن اكثر
ولايتين متضررتين في تركيا وفي جنوب تركيا
هما كهرمان مرعش وغازي عنتاب ويقول ايضا
ضيفنا من غازي عنتاب السيد فايز الاسمر
المحلل العسكري بانه لم يشهد ولم يرى مثل
هذه الهزه في حياته يتحدث عن هزه عنيفه
وطويله امتدت اكثر من ثلاث دقائق يعني في
العاده تكون الهزات مجرد ثواني معدوده لكن
سيد فايز الاسمر الذي عاش في قلب الحدث
لحظه وقوع
الزلزال والهزات الارتداديه هو وعائلته
وايضا ابناء هذه المنطقه في غازي عنتاب في
جنوب تركيا بان هذه المنطقه لم تشهد زلزال
مدمرا في حياتهم يعني منذ سنوات بهذا
الحجم طبعا عمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره